salut éternel salut les terriens ce soir
en p1 nous accueillons pierre et gilles
eh bien j'ai le bon soir est assez vous
le photographe gilles c'est vous le
peintre vous êtes les auteurs
d'inoubliables image de star et
d'inconnu inspiré de saint sulpice de
bollywood qui connaissent un succès
mondial mérité et vous êtes ici ce soir
pour répondre à la question que se
posent tous nos téléspectateurs est ce
que vous êtes ensemble
à ton avis
[Applaudissements]
a mon avis oui l'émission s'appelle
salut les terriens et le groupe les
gréements sorte
[Musique]
gilles rebond soir après philippe starck
est sûre louboutin jean charles de
castelbajac et jean paul gaultier dans
la série ardisson reçoit ses potes du
palace j'accueille donc ce soir pierre
jean bienvenue parmi nous
alors pour ceux qui ne vous
connaîtraient pas on peut dire que vous
êtes les deux seuls mecs à pouvoir
rendre culte un portrait de mireille
mathieu
babaud d'aller fort alors qu'hier comme
moi vous êtes né en vendée à la roche
sur yon en 1950 tempérament artistique
précoce à 13 ans vous chanter au casino
de luchon
oui en fait c'étaient des concours de
chant et ça m'amusait beaucoup j'avais
eu le premier prix de la wii je pense
pas que c'était la voix c'est plutôt les
le look et gestes et donc après les
études à genève est un service militaire
à provins lui débarqué à paris à l'âge
de 23 ans nous travailler comme
photographe pour des revues de mode
comme depeche mode des revues musicales
comme rock-folk
gilles blanchard vous êtes née au havre
en 1953 à 15 ans vous entré à l'académie
des beaux-arts locale puis en 1974 où
vous installer à paris pour faire les
arts déco parallèlement vous réalisez
des illustrations pour la publicité et
les magazines et c'est en 1976 que vous
rencontrez à l'occasion de la fête pour
l'ouverture de la boutique kenzo place
des victoires un ami vous présente et
vous repartez ensemble sur le même
scooter
alors
est-ce que ce soir là vous aviez assez
bu pour pas être trop timides
oui on avait bien du jour là et bien là
que le dessus et on était très timide
tous les deux c'est pour ça que ça a
marché vous êtes plus quittés depuis non
non non ça mais 76 ça d'abord été une
rencontre une histoire d'amour et c'est
quelques temps après on a travaillé on
se travaille alors pierre a pris une
amie en photo gilles s'amuse à repeindre
par dessus pour mettre des couleurs plus
vives et vous dites on a compris qu'on
avait trouvé quelque chose et on a
travaillé ensemble ils avaient pris
conscience de votre complémentarité
artistique oui il a ce qu'on sentait
tellement bien ensemble ensemble on
santé beaucoup plus du sort et on
s'amusait plus aux indices c'est ça qui
est important
il faut s'amuser maison alors à l'époque
moi je collaborais un journal simple et
façades magazine créé par alain benoit
re et j'ai vu arriver vos premières
images à la rédaction du journal la
première que j'ai vu c'était être
vigilent été l'égérie ponctuellement
avec une cravate en bandes velpeau c'est
cette image que j'ai repeint la première
phase et là j'ai découvert le plaisir de
peindre d'imagés le plaisir de
travailler ensemble alors pour façades
vous photographiez andy warhol salvador
dali mick jagger yves saint laurent iggy
pop bien sûr au départ cette idée de
photos repentis étaient pas très bien vu
par les l'establishment de la photo à
paris c'était l'époque
où la photo a été très classique encore
le noir et blanc était considérée comme
la photo artistique en étant en pleine
époque punk aussi foudroyé c'était le
côté très dur et nous nos amis étaient
punk mais on était toujours décalé ouais
mais bien ça en plus on recadre et nos
images on faisait tout à notre façon
rapidement votre travail qui est
extrêmement rigoureux sans concession
moi je m'en souviens quand on vous
demandait un changement c'était des
discussions infinies votre travail
s'impose alors comment ça se passe on
discute ou les pierres qui dessine quand
même des qui dessine tout devient plus
clair c'est ça qui est fort hills vial
son 2eme mois j'explique il dessine et
c'est qu'on a quand l'idée prend forme
bon on construit le décor voilà ce qu'il
faut dire c'est qu'au travail très
artisanal
et on aime bien travaillé tous les deux
et toujours n'a pas changé c'est de la
chance et puis ensuite pierre prend la
photo et vous vous intervenez sur tirage
voilà pour équilibrer pour toute aide en
images tout est dans le décor le ciel
les fleurs tout est là le personnage est
réellement dans le décor comme au
théâtre il ya toujours le décor c'est à
vous faites pas des images séparées vous
plaquer ensuite repas démontage du tout
à l'époque y avait pas le numérique et
toi ça déjà c'est vrai alors vos
influences passées le le pop art
évidemment bollywood aussi parce que
j'ai fait des voyages en armes lindon au
maroc est un point de départ de notre
voyage marque on a vu des images de
abdelhalim hafez
alors il ya aussi une influence
importante de l'art saint sulpiciens
parce que vous avez été élevé tous les
deux dans le catholicisme
j'étais enfant de choeur déjà à
légitimer toutes les religions nous ont
toujours fasciné autant les religions
indien
c'est les images religieuses en général
- quand vous étiez petit on vous on vous
montrait des diapositives du christ et
piquant quand il quand il pleuvait on
vous emmener voir des films religieux a
oui j'ai vraiment bien et là dedans j'ai
un frère qui est moine aussi on est dans
votre philipson
d'alors veut inventer un monde féerique
vous dites c'est comme si on écrivait de
jolies chansons et des poésies
on rêve le monde en sachant bien qu'il
ne sera pas comme ça on en a besoin
parce que la réalité c'est vrai elle est
très dure très cruel une effrayante on a
besoin de rêver c'est vraiment tout
c'est autant le la façon de vivre tous
les jours que
la maison comme elle est décorée
incroyable ce que vous faites en dans
vos images c'est exactement votre
appartement en fin de saison et c'est on
est baigné là dedans alors fabriquer une
vingtaine d'oeuvres par an à peu près
non un peu près alors le 30 mai 2011 le
petit jardinier a été vendu quand même
150 7000 euros chez christie's quand
même
je vais dire quelque chose
j'ai dû commencer à l'époque vous gagnez
pas d'argent il eu des périodes
extrêmement difficile vous n'avez jamais
cédé vous avez toujours refusé de
travailler l'un sans l'autre va être
tout fait ensemble
vous avez pris une ligne vous êtes allé
au bout et aujourd'hui si ça paye ça
n'est que justice l'argent s'est jamais
ta moteur tournant c'est plutôt de créer
une star cette vie vous la raconter dans
un beau livre publié aux éditions bazar
en collaboration avec thomas doustaly
qui est l'éditeur et paquita paquin
intitulé autobiographie en photomaton
alors tout a commencé comme un jeu
d'enfant gilles en sortant du lycée au
havre vous attendait le bus à côté d'un
photomaton
le challenge c'est de se dire est-ce que
je vais avoir le temps de faire une
faute aux matons et je savais que si je
voyais pas le bus au bout de l'avenue
je disais j'ai le temps de le faire mais
c'était juste alors à partir de là
pendant 20 ans vous allez faire des
photomatons de vos proches de votre
famille de vos amis raconte toute mon
histoire la rencontre avec pierre et
tous les toute l'époque du talent à 6 à
tous les amis et derrière se font très
simple un rideau et tout ça on imagine
toute une époque alors il ya tous les
gens du palace évidemment il ya eva
dryats yabon bouhila jenny bel'air il ya
exige eva ionesco christian louboutin
farik à marie france alain pacadis kenzo
ou alors certains ont disparu est un peu
dur à faire ce livre à ce niveau là il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ont disparu
quand même beaucoup c'est effectivement
le vestige moeckli d'une époque
insouciante vous dites on pensait
surtout pas d'avenir ont refusé le
travail on voulait s'amuser je pense que
pour créer il faut s'amuser ils vivront
peut pas créer sans enfermer comme ça
surtout quand on est jeune il faut
vraiment découvrir tout c'est vrai qu'on
s'amusait bien les années 70 quand on
était gay drogué artistes
mais tous n'ont été mélangés unité de
mélange c'est ça qui était forme
sphérique au palace on pouvait
rencontrer yves saint laurent à 5 heures
du matin assis sur un escalier avec un
garçon joie fleurs en pleine
conversation tout à fait ça change et ça
c'était formidable alors tout va bien
pour vous donc sur les conseils de carla
bruni nicolas sarkozy vous a choisi pour
son prochain portrait officiel alors on
va passer de ça à ça
ou à ça
alors pour françois hollande
vous pensez à quelque chose comme ça
voilà
très bien régime
en revanche je suis pas sûre de notre
idée pour le pape moi personnellement
les corrections de ne rien rater le in a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu